THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
ANIMATED SHORT PROVE THAT WHILE
YOU MAY END UP WORKING IN
ANIMATION, YOUR INSPIRATION CAN
COME FROM ALL SORTS
OF PLACES.
ADRIEN MERIGEAU'S VERY FIRST
FAVORITE FILM WAS "HEDGEHOG IN
THE FOG" AND AMAURY OVISE'S
FAVORITE LINE,
"ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?"
FROM "TAXI DRIVER,"
WAIT, DID I DO THAT RIGHT?
"ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?"
DO I SOUND LIKE HIM?
FUELED THE MOVIE LOVE THAT
INSPIRED THEM TO MAKE "GENIUS LOCI."
"YES-PEOPLE'S" ARNAR GUNNARSSON
AND GISLI DARRI HALLDORSSON'S
LOVE AFFAIR WITH
ANIMATION BEGAN
WITH "STAR WARS."
THE FORCE IS VERY
STRONG WITH THOSE TWO.
ERICK OH SPENT HOURS AND HOURS
WATCHING FILMS BY LEGENDARY
ANIMATION DIRECTOR
MIYAZAKI HAYAO.
THOSE HOURS INSPIRED HIM TO
CREATE THE FILM "OPERA."
MADELINE SHARAFIAN IS A HUGE FAN
OF WES ANDERSON FILMS.
AND HER PARTNER, MICHAEL
CAPBARAT IS A HUGE FAN OF A
LARGE COKE AND A SMALL POPCORN.
BOTH HELPED TO FUEL THEM TO
CREATE THEIR FILM "BURROW."
MICHAEL GOVIER'S FAVORITE FILM
AT 12 YEARS OLD WAS "CITIZEN KANE."
REALLY, 12 YEARS OLD?
THAT'S VERY INTENSE
TO WATCH "CITIZEN KANE."
BUT WILL MCCORMAC'S
FAVORITE FILM IS "ORDINARY PEOPLE"
ALSO, A VERY INTENSE FILM.
WILL ALSO ENJOYS THE
UNIQUE COMBINATION
OF POURING MILK DUDS INTO HIS
SMALL POPCORN, WHICH SOUNDS AWESOME
SORT OF LIKE HIS FAVORITE FILM,
"ORDINARY PEOPLE"
IT'S SORT OF SALTY AND MESSY
AND DEFINITELY DELICIOUS.
THEY BOTH WORKED TOGETHER TO GIVE
US, "IF ANYTHING HAPPENS I LOVE YOU."
SO, HERE IT IS, THE OSCAR GOES TO
THE BEST ANIMATED SHORT FILM --
"IF ANYTHING HAPPENS I LOVE YOU"
WILL MCCORMAC AND
MICHAEL GOVIER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D GET
TO SAY THIS
THANK YOU TO THE ACADEMY.
I JUST WANT TO THANK -- JUST
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO OPENED
THEIR HEARTS AND
WATCHED OUR FILM.
IT JUST MEANS SO
MUCH TO US.
MARYANN GARGER, YOU
WERE THE ENGINE OF OUR FILM
YOUNGRAN NHO,
YOUR ART ASTOUNDS US,
LAURA DERN AND
JAYME LEMONS,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TENACITY AND PASSION.
GARY GILBERT AND GILBERT
FILMS FOR BELIEVING IN US.
ROBYN KLEIN AND JEREMY ROSS,
OUR GUARDIAN ANGELS.
LINDSAY MARCUS,
YOUR SUBLIME MUSIC.
PETER MORGAN.
GERALD CHAMALES,
SYDNEY HOLLAND AND PETER ETTINGER,
MICHAEL BABCOCK, JULIA
RODRIGUES AND MICHELLE HEO.
WE WERE SO LUCKY TO WORK WITH YOU.
THAT'S HOW BIG OUR TEAM WAS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY PARENTS
WHO'VE BEEN MY CHAMPIONS
FROM THE START.
MY WIFE ELIZA, I LOVE YOU.
>> THANK YOU TO RASHIDA JONES,
MELISSA COBB, GREGG TAYLOR.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE GUTS
TO BELIEVE THAT ALL STORIES
CAN BE TOLD IN ANIMATION.
WOLF KASTELER, NOELLE ROY,
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY,
SOPHIE YEN AND THE
UTA FOUNDATION.
MOM AND DAD FOR TELLING ME
I COULD DO ANYTHING I BELIEVED IN.
I BOUGHT IT.
MY WIFE EMILY ARLOOK AND OUR BABY BOY
SONNY MCCORMACK, YOU BROUGHT ME MORE
JOY THAN I KNEW WAS POSSIBLE.
WE DEDICATE THIS FILM TO ALL
THOSE WHO'VE LOST LOVED ONES
TO GUN VIOLENCE.
WE DESERVE BETTER THAN TO LIVE
IN A COUNTRY WHERE MORE THAN
100 PEOPLE DIE BY GUN VIOLENCE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE DESERVE BETTER.
WE MUST BE BETTER.
WE WILL DO BETTER.
THANK YOU.